hey guys Ryan righteous here and Breanna
White's us here top-five lesbian scenes
and gaming from zoom-in games let's do
this games can be so shameless sometimes
and that's one of the many reasons why
not and of them it's time for some hot
girl-on-girl action in this top 5
lesbian themes in gaming my favorite
take a magic trick Pizza fee effect to
retro helix might have been a social
game but it had something most games
didn't I love seeing with chicks don't
worry
maybe the dress of wah-wah interesting
tactic Hannah what tactic shall we
continue lucky or not it's still pretty
hot I can show you what I have in mind
let it Dragon Age 2 as a femme Hawk and
you might end up in a steamy love scene
with tough lady pirate Isabel
[Music]
I would've used the place
although things awkward the next morning
that was thank you I should go I
wouldn't want to take advantage of your
hospitality my cute I don't want you
wandering the streets alone at this hour
you're sweet but I can watch out for
myself
wait you're not thinking of bringing
feelings into this are you the life of a
witch is full of surprises
one moment you are fighting monsters in
the forest the next moment you stumble
upon a lesbian
BDSM session
[Music]
you're right we love how they pretend
like nothing happened
I tried locating trace but the mist
disrupts the mega scoop there's a weak
signal nearby probably on the other side
guess hottie lesbian action is no biggie
in the pinky which is universal
I'll find you when you enter the mist
farewell then I figured you'd be more
interested in this yes that was an
option
it's an option if you play Mass Effect 3
as fem shep you have the option to
romance lesbian crew member Samantha
tree no bet you need a cold shower after
this she's interested in
mr. Neff
which I needed that are you using me for
my shower I certainly hope so
well in that case it's yours whenever
you like when you think it is since you
probably don't think hot lesbian kissing
but you're wrong the sims is the
ultimate tool for dude yourself lesbian
makeup sessions you can build your dream
girls and if you then tend to lovemaking
from any angle
Wow much craziness it might really not a
creepy pervert lesbian action that
doesn't get any better than this
[Music]
wanna be friends the one er on the
channel what's your name come on over
that little ending there was really
weird hey hey really weird what she was
doing what what I was saying what she
was doing okay good yeah no you are not
weird when you get like that so I've
actually never played through The
Witcher series I tried to play through
which or two on I think like the Xbox
360 and it was just not that interesting
to me yeah but I feel like now I have to
play it the witchery games that are
always credited for their sex scenes and
stuff yeah whenever I see like a list
like this I did not know about that
domination scene man's dominating each
other
sweet Bullock and hot that's [__] hot
so I actually played through both the
Dragon Age scenes and the Bioware scene
VMs vaccine I played through both of
those so I I've seen those before
could you get into like gaming lets me
and stuff like enjoy it sure finally
erotic and turned on a little bit really
that's why they're there okay that's
fair point that's a fair point
right yeah it's also like I mean and
that's probably the difference for me
between like The Witcher scene or like
The Sims 3 thing versus like Mass Effect
or Dragon Age is because you know I
actually read my best to fix literate
nose laughing cool that's pretty awesome
yeah the difference for me is the story
right so like with Sims that's just just
playing dolls basically that's not
interesting yeah it's like human minions
I don't find that very like interesting
at all yeah that's true because I mean
they're also the graphics just aren't
good enough for you to be like oh that's
hot and they're not even really locking
lips their faces are staying exactly
they're like glitching and inside it's
not hot so then what were the daggers
that's Isabelle I think her name's
Isabella I don't know if it's if that's
right it's a bell but anyways so the fun
of it is that you kind of think that
she's gonna kill you the entire time
yeah thanks sleeping with her
Nakul she's kind of a [__] though the
next day next morning um isn't that
every person's dream no consequence sex
no what if you do end up having feelings
for the person you know I think there is
an option later in the game to actually
have a relationship with her so you just
have to kind of warm up a bit like when
Veronica and I first had sex I was like
so in love with her and she wanted
nothing to do with me she actually got a
restraining order once I paid her enough
money she agreed to go out with me
so until her contracts up in the year
2018 that dragon gonna be together I
take care of her financially pretty
awesome she does what I needed to do
they're in love we're in love this is
love people welcome to America the
Dragon Age - I mean you know she's black
and she's white I like that interracial
stuff I don't know if she's black I
think she's like she looks black she's
like a pirate so I think she's just like
everything ambiguous interesting
interesting you know it must have been
really hard for them to pick from only
one scene in in Dragon Age 2 and only
well in the whole Dragon Age series
because there's romance options for all
of them
so I agree with the one with Isabella
like that's that's a great scene but as
far as Mass Effect goes there's actually
seen in Mass Effect one where your
secretary will do a lot they will do not
your striptease for you oh nice yeah so
I'm kind of surprised not to see that
one in there yeah I think the Dragon Age
one was the best one because I'm into
that kind of like you know you're just
so like connected with someone and
you're so rough at the same time and
you're yeah kind of cool no it's like
attrition you know their mouths game
that's kind of the fun of it yeah yeah
is my girlfriend when I see her totally
should just let me see Foley
gotta pay extra for that yeah you know
what it's more cinematic I feel like
it's way more anxious when there's more
of an emotional kind of context like
like sometimes you could watch a sex
scene in a movie
give you really hot especially from a
female's perspective a lot of the time
that's compared to watching a porno like
yeah these are two people [__] each
other like when you're like invested in
characters or like you know them if
that's what it's like you really it
calls back to that like cat-and-mouse
thing you were talking about you know
sometimes not seeing it is almost even
sexier because you get to have the
mystery in your head yeah and you know
they do whatever I want them to do in my
head and that's what's cool they do like
to create the strap-ons
those things that like you touch them
and then it burns like a little shocker
think the things you Brandi kind of it's
like you poke them if they and their
burns no it's called putting putting
like a step beyond like candle wax but a
bunch of clothes pins on nipples of all
things yeah yeah tying them up oh gosh
yeah yeah Mass Effect 3 is the best game
and for people anyway guys if you're new
to the channel subscribe today to the
real rejects click this button that
Breanna white does not approve of and
thinks I could have much better quality
you can check out Breanna White's gaming
channel what's better than a hot blonde
playing video games nothing nothing at
all nothing not even the stuff I made up
in Mass Effect 3 that's avec de Simlish
okay English is that that works right
yeah Simlish English yeah that's also a
sex position uh-huh interesting that's
where your do you have pixels all over
your body yeah you're pixelated and then
you're eating out the girl and then she
squirts goo on you that's kind of like
you know I was 23 but I need your mother
like the alien thing just wraps around
you and then next thing you that's how
the xenomorph was formed was from a
woman's squirting
the Simlish the birth of the xenomorph
watching oh I'm so flattered